greetings I'm here with Jimmy and we
just got to check out the PlayStation 4
Pro I think one of the big questions
people have about the PlayStation 4 pro
is how it's doing 4k and they kind of
explained how that works do you mind
kind of going into that just a little
bit sure yeah so yeah as you mentioned
one of the most popular questions is can
ps4 really to 4k and the answer as it
turns out is kind of complicated so I
think it's fair to say if it's like a
simple simplistic looking game that you
know isn't to graphically demanding then
yes it can do native 3840 by 2160 p
which is what most people consider to be
4k but most games will be using an
upscaled 4k mode which Sony calls a
checkerboard rendering and I think about
2/3 of their launch games are going to
be are going to use that and before I
describe what that process is like I
hope you don't mind if I draw out you
know how 1080p and 4k is rendered go for
it
so in a typical 1080p resolution you
have a pixel represented as let's
represent as a square and in the square
there's a shader and shaders basically
like a color so you know one you have
one square with one shader
in the same space for 4k monitor a 4k
panel you'll actually have 4 pixels each
with their own shader so that's you know
four times with checkerboard rendering
what you're having is it actually
instead of pixels being represented in a
square they're actually represented in
like a rectangle and it occupies half
the shader density as 4k but it does it
in like a criss cross checkerboard
pattern and you know apparently
according to Sony doing so is an
effective shortcut that will you know
give you something that looks close to
4k without the performance impact yeah I
think what most people are probably
curious about is how does this look does
it measure up to 4k I mean both you and
I got to sort of do a blind test to see
if we could tell the difference and we
did get it but I mean it was pretty hard
to tell
right yeah you know towards the end of
the presentation that we had with with
mark Cerny we both got to see sort of
like a blind test case of 4k native 3840
by 2160 versus this checker board 4k and
I think we saw what was what was the
game again days gone days gone right and
you know they had two 4k TVs you know
side-by-side and we I think we both were
able to guess which one was the
oppressed version um I think I noticed I
looked at the back of his head the main
character's hat and you could like I
could tell like the linen stitching on
the back of his head wasn't quite as
crisp and I think you noticed that the
colors didn't look as rich because
there's actually like half the color
data so that kind of makes sense I'm
having said that though it looks really
close you know how close would you say
it looks I'd say it's like 98% there
maybe 95 I because the only way I could
tell the difference was when I did get
up really close like I must been within
six inches of that screen just trying to
find little little little clues basic
right it is it is pretty impressive and
we also did see demos of you know of the
up-res of checkerboard rendering versus
the native 1080p and there was to me
there was a pretty stark difference so I
think the final question then would be
is do you think it's worth upgrading to
the PlayStation 4 Pro so we will be
reviewing it when it comes out in
November until then I think my gut is
saying if you have a 4k / HDR TV and
don't have a Playstation 4 and are
looking to get a game console I think
it's a very good buy I think if you have
a ps4 and are sitting on a 1080p TV it
doesn't make too much sense I think that
there are going to be some titles that
will look better at 1080p but I would
probably hold off on on you know
upgrading until until we get a better
you know list of titles to support that
great for more on the PlayStation 4 Pro
be sure to stay tuned to games but and
we'll see you guys soon
[Music]
you
[Music]